so what you see here this is a
screenshot of the desmos online graphing
calculator you can use it at desmos.com
and i encourage you to use this after
this video or even while i'm doing this
video but the goal here is to think
about reflection of functions so let's
just start with some examples
let's say that i had a function f of x
and it is equal to
the square root
of x so that's what it looks like fairly
reasonable
now let's make another function g of x
and i'll start off by also making that
the square root of x so no surprise
there g of x was graphed right on top of
f of x
but what would happen
if instead of it just being the square
root of x what would happen if we put a
negative out front right over there what
do you think is going to happen when i
do that
well let's just try it out when i put
the negative it looks like it flipped it
over the x-axis it looks like it
reflected it over the x-axis
now instead of doing it that way what if
we had another function h of x
and i'll start off
by making it identical to f of x so once
again it's right over there it traces
out f of x
instead of putting the negative out in
front of the radical sign what if we put
it under the radical sign what if we
replaced x with a negative x what do you
think is going to happen there
well let's try it out
if we replace it
that shifted it over the y-axis
and then pause this video and think
about how would you shift it over both
axes
well we could do a well i'm running out
of letters maybe i will do a i don't
know k of x
is equal to so i'm going to put the
negative outside the radical sign
and then i'm going to take the square
root and i'm going to put a negative
inside the radical side and notice it
flipped it over both it flipped it over
both the x-axis and the y-axis to go
over here
now why does this happen let's just
start with the g of x
so when you put the negative out in
front when you negate everything that's
in the expression that defines a
function whatever
value you would have gotten of the
function before you're now going to get
the opposite of it so
when
x is zero we got zero when x is one
instead of one now you're taking the
negative of it so you're going to get
negative 1.
when x is 4 instead of getting positive
2 you're now going to get negative 2.
when x is equal to 9 instead of getting
positive 3 you now get negative 3. so
hopefully that makes sense why putting a
negative out front of an entire
expression is going to flip it over flip
its graph over the x-axis
now what about replacing an x with a
negative x
well one way to think about it now is
whatever whenever you inputted one
before that would now be a negative one
that you're trying to evaluate the
principal root of and we know that the
principal root function is not defined
for negative one
but when x is equal to negative one our
original function wasn't defined there
when x is equal to negative 1 but if you
take the negative of that well now
you're taking this principal root of 1.
and so that's why it is now defined so
whatever value the function would have
taken on at a given value of x it now
takes that value on the corresponding
opposite value of x and on the negative
value of that x and so that's why it
flips it over the y-axis and this is
true with many types of functions we
don't have to do this just with a square
root function let's try another function
let's say
we tried this for
e
to the
x power
so there you go we have a very classic
exponential there now let's say that g
of x is equal to negative e to the x and
if what we expect to happen happens this
will flip it over the x axis
so negative e
to the x power and indeed that is what
happens
and then how would we flip it over the
y axis
well let's do an h of x
that's going to be equal to e
to the instead of putting an x there we
will put a negative x
negative x and there you have it notice
it flipped it over the y axis
now both examples that i just did these
are very simple expressions let's
imagine something that's a little bit
more complex
let's say that f of x let's give it a
nice
higher degree polynomial so let's say
it's x to the third
minus
2 x squared that's a nice one and
actually let's just add another term
here so plus
2 x and i want to make it let me get
minus 2x i want to accentuate some of
those curves all right so that's a
pretty interesting graph
now how would i
flip it over the x-axis
well the way that i would do that is i
could define a g of x i could do it two
ways i could say g of x is equal to the
negative of f of x
and we get that so that's essentially
just taking this entire expression and
multiplying it by negative 1. and notice
it's multiplying it it's flipping it
over the x-axis another way we could
have done it is instead of that we could
have said the negative of
x to the third
minus
minus 2x
squared
and then minus
2x and then we close those parentheses
and we get the same effect
now what if we wanted to flip it over
the y-axis
well then instead of putting a negative
on the entire expression what we want to
do is replace our x's with a negative x
so you could do it like this you could
say
that that's going to be f of negative x
and that has the effect of everywhere
you saw an x before you replace it with
a negative x and notice it did exactly
what we expect it flipped it over over
the y axis
now the other way we could have done
that just to make it clear that's the
same thing as negative x
to the third power
minus 2
times negative x
squared
minus
2 times negative x and of course we
could simplify that expression but
notice it has the exact same idea
and if we wanted to flip it over both
the x and y axes
well we've already flipped it over the y
axis to flip it over the x-axis whoops i
just deleted it to flip it over
the i'm having issues here to flip it
over
the x-axis as well
we would have gave me a parenthesis
already i would just put a negative out
front so i put a negative out front and
there you have it this flipped it over
both the x and y-axis you can do them in
either order and you will get to this
green curve now an easier way of writing
that would have been just the negative
of f of
negative
x
and you would have gotten to that same
place
so go to desmos play around with it
really good to build this intuition and
really understand why it's happening